hello everyone Karen morning with film
courage the radio show well we're
continuing our PMD discussion outside
the studio of la talk radio with John
Reese and 17 Bianco and there were a lot
of questions that we left on the table
one of which is a hypothetical case
study let's suppose we have a $250,000
film no major stars and no major film
festivals how would you begin marketing
the film okay so basically with any film
I tell filmmakers to first think about
what their goals are and because
different strategies will result in
different I mean different goals will
result in different strategies and how
they're going to approach that film and
then also to think about the resources
in your giving 250,000 and basically I
would say as a rule of thumb although it
doesn't apply to every film it's like
5050 if you have $250,000 you should
have only spent 125 on your distribution
on the making of the film and saved 125
thousand dollars or something like that
for the distribution of marketing of the
film and then it also is audience
centric it's like who is the audience
for the film and your strategy will be
determined by how you engage that
audience you know how you find out you
need to find out where that audience
receives information and you need to
figure out how that audience consumes
media and you have to think about what
that audience is interested in and how
you can engage that audience through the
different kinds of media that you create
and one of the things that I think is
very important is that filmmakers not
just thinking not just think about
creating a feature film and but and they
don't necessarily need to go to a
full-fledged transmedia project but
filmmakers need to start thinking about
creating different kinds of assets that
are just the EPK that aren't just extra
features on a DVD but that are ways
across platforms to engage audience and
so all of these things combined I think
that you're saying that that filmmaker
has students or $50,000 made
for 250 is that the film festival at the
film festival point where they finish
the film about this event of film
festivals I think what I would say is
need that filmmaker who has $250,000 and
is about to make a film but is then
thinking about how you're going to make
a film and then also engage audiences
how you're going to recoup your money if
that's what's important to you how
you're going to get this film out to a
broad audience if that's what it's
important to you how are you going to
develop yours and your team's career
over time if that's what's important to
you and to do that from the beginning
and that if I have one mantra that is to
at the very beginning of your project
think about not just how you're going to
make your film but how you're going to
get that film out into the world and
engage audiences because if you wait
until you finish your film and you're
submitting into festivals to meet you've
kind of like it's not too late but you
kind of shot yourself in the foot it'll
be a much better position if you move
and start that process much earlier and
as close to inception the better
absolutely I totally you know I I think
in terms of whatever resources you have
it's just really laying a good plan you
know and and having not only well here's
the plan that we envisioned here's how
it fits within two hundred fifty
thousand dollars you know this is this
is this is all of the assets we're going
to create this is you know the audience
we we have and how we're going to engage
with them and you know we have this much
in our budget for that and how can we
make those things work you know maybe we
can't go full transmedia maybe we really
want to but we just can't afford it you
know in some ways I mean there's
definitely low-budget transmedia ways to
gauge but I think yeah just you know
what's your plan and what's your budget
and how can you you know you it's always
a give and take you know every every
filmmaker with always a lot more money
to make their film and you know why you
know why can I make a million-dollar
film while you can you know so here's
what you have and here you know figure
out how to work with that I think what's
even saying in terms of having a plan is
exactly right like in that that you know
filmmakers were used to making this
plans and I think part of that business
planet or good percentage of that
business plan needs to be a distribution
of marketing plans so that you have from
it from the inception you have an idea
of how you're going to get this film out
into the world it doesn't mean that
you're going to be lockstep to that plan
because as you discover who your
audience is and may not your audience
may not be the audience that you thought
of at the beginning my team may not be
so you have to be pretty facile and be
able to think on your feet and be able
to adjust you know and but you have to
start with this awareness to start early
so let's suppose you you have a good
idea of who your audience is what's a
DIY approach to finding out how they
consume their media I mean if it's not
the 18 to 34 male demographic then you
know that well then you know you know
those those types are going to find most
of their stuff online but what if it's
something with supposed cocoon the film
cocoon so it's an older audience I'm
dating myself here but how are those
people how are we going to find out
where they get their media well I think
that the key is is before you find out
how they consume media is to find out is
to kind of find out who they are and you
know how they in fact consume
information you know so say there's a
film called the singing revolution which
was about the Estonian revolution and
they actually their audiences an older
audience and they bought a lot of dvds
they are not only bottle I DVDs but the
filmmakers made a CD if you can believe
it of the music that in the film and the
music an Estonian folk songs and that
audience bought a lot of those so this
is a medium that you think is gone the
CD but there's still audiences that
consume media in that way so they were
smart to think about what their audience
consumes and they through research and
then they created a product for them
that they would buy you know so I think
part of it is you know I think it's
smart exploration of social media but
also smart exploration of organizations
I think it's really important that
filmmakers see if there's organizations
that are that pertain to their audiences
and to engage with those audio those
organizations to reach
audiences and this is I know something
that Steven and Mark are doing on the
film how to live forever and as much as
possible if you if there are
organizations organized around your
audience to try to engage those those
organizations and this is yet another
reason why I think filmmakers need to
start this process from inception
because those organizations will be much
more receptive to you and working with
you if you involve them in the process
if you come to them with a finished film
and say hey I made this film about blot
aging for instance you know but you've
never talked to them beforehand and they
say oh that's kind of nice and you know
whereas if you and I know mark did talk
to some of these organizations while he
was making the film and engage them in
the process then they're going to be
much more involved with the film and
have an feel like they have an ownership
over the whole project which is the same
way as any audience member if you
involve them from the beginning they're
going to feel like they have an
ownership in it and a stake in that film
that you're making you know they're
going to feel part of the team and
that's you know that's what you're
looking for yeah I think it's funny you
mentioned cocoon because I mean this
movie have a live forever you know
cocoon you have the senior citizens who
they find the Fountain of Youth you know
it's these pods that Yul swimming and
they feel great and whatever and you
know how to live forever we're very much
interested in a lot of you know that
audience says it's so you know a lot of
the work is is researching them and who
are these audiences and it's and it's
not just automatically who you know who
you might think the audiences you know
there's a whole variety of possible
audiences who might be interested in
this you know not just people who care
about stories about senior citizens and
not just people who care about aging but
also you know what about other other
people who care about health and
exercise and nutrition and it just it
one thing leads to another and you're
like wow this is I really have to get a
handle on my audience and it's a lot of
work to do that but it's so critical to
laying that blend